[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Rosa Pérez mateu conmigo en
el estudio Rosa hoy vamos a hablar de
China y empezamos con un artículo que
dice el partido comunista de China
excluye de la cúpula del poder a las
mujeres es un artículo que escribió
Guillermo abril para el diario El País
exactamente Buenos días Raúl y es que
tras la clausura del vigésimo congreso
del partido comunista de China hubo
algunos ejes que se destacaron en los
principales medios de comunicación
alrededor del mundo entre ellos el súper
comentado que fue esta renovación para
un inédito tercer mandato de momento
como secretario general del partido para
otro lado también el hecho de que el
presidente chino se rodeo de miembros
muy fieles a él tanto en el comité
permanente como en el polít buró donde
además todos los integrantes son de la
etnia hand que es la mayoritaria en
China pero no la única como sabemos
sí por otro lado una cuestión de género
no y es que por primera vez en más de 20
años No hay ninguna mujer entre los 24
miembros del polit buró que sería por
decirlo rápidamente el segundo órgano en
la jerarquía de poder del partido
comunista hasta ahora Cabe señalar que
sunland era la única mujer que formaba
parte de este órgano pero que sin
embargo alcanza ya los 72 años y por lo
tanto le llega el momento de retirarse a
pesar de ser hasta ahora una figura con
muchísimo peso dentro de la política
china se considera que ella ha sido de
las principales encargadas al frente de
la gestión de la pandemia y además tenía
Rango de Vice primera ministra pero no
hay un reemplazo digamos en el único
asiento destinado a una mujer no ha
habido otra mujer que la ocupara además
Guillermo abril dice la tendencia hacia
el cero absoluto continúa en los órganos
de poder que han emergido del clave en
el nuevo comité central que consta de
205 miembros con derecho a voto solo hay
11 mujeres y eso a pesar de que en su
discurso inaugural
dijo Seguiremos comprometidos con la
política nacional fundamental de
igualdad de género y además de esta cita
no ha mencionada en muchísimos medios de
comunicación cuando se ha comentado este
tema de la desaparición de las mujeres
del polít buró y es esta cita de Mao de
que las mujeres sostienen la mitad del
cielo y dice el periodista del país que
si bien Mao las educó y contribuyó a su
integración al mercado laboral
retribuido pues eso no significó una
representación No digamos firme en a los
altos rangos de poder Rosa vamos con la
ausencia de mujeres en una élite de
liderazgo de China es Un paso atrás
según un analistas del saus chinamor en
Post exactamente en la misma línea este
medio a chino lo que Comenta Es algunas
de las razones por las que las mujeres
no aparecen en los altos órganos en los
altos niveles de poder y atribuye un
poco a esta situación lo que sería pues
un esquema clásico de machismo que se da
en China así como en Pues todo el mundo
con mayor o menor nivel no dice que si
bien hay cuotas en digamos ciertos
ámbitos de la Administración sobre todo
local y regional para que entre un 10 y
un 15% de los cargos estén ocupados por
mujeres esto ya no pasa en los altos
niveles y que además se suelencasillar a
las mujeres en ciertos ámbitos de la
Administración como la educación o la
cultura luego por ejemplo no sé la
ciencia o las organizaciones de masas y
que eso en cierto modo las estanca
porque dice la única forma de progresar
hacia lo alto de la jerarquía del
partido comunista es básicamente ocupar
cargos en los que uno pueda demostrar
que sabe impulsar el desarrollo
económico y nos da otras cifras este
artículo Y es que por ejemplo
básicamente para empezar desde la base
de los 1.400 millones de habitantes de
China básicamente la mitad son mujeres y
que unos 28 millones de mujeres forman
parte del partido comunista lo que
supone entorno al 30% de los miembros de
esta organización y básicamente
dentro del partido hay unos dos millones
de cuadros que están ocupados por
mujeres lo que supone un
26,5% del total no y que básicamente en
este en este comité en este congreso del
partido comunista de los 2.300 delegados
una 27% aproximadamente eran mujeres y
esto no dista mucho Raúl como vamos a
ver ahora de la situación en otros
países Así es el medio fina por Estados
Unidos radio free ella arroja también
algunas cifras interesantes Rosa
Exactamente no y es que como bien
decíamos un 27% más o menos de los
delegados en este vigésimo congreso del
partido comunista eran mujeres y ahí
radio fría Asia lo compara con la
situación en los órganos legislativos
por ejemplo de la Unión Europea en que
dice los escaños están ocupados
solamente en un 30% por mujeres también
Pero además Raúl comentar otra situación
Y es que en el texto de radio frías
también habla no de este machismo a
través de distintas voces que critican
lo que decíamos no el techo de cristal y
varios elementos clásicos Pues que
encontramos en la sociedad machista como
consecuencia de estas estructuras y
entre otras señalan que muchas mujeres
se consideran máquinas de bebés debido a
las políticas de natalidad
implantadas por el gobierno chino tanto
cuando
rigió la política del Sol de un solo
hijo como ahora que el gobierno está
alenta a las mujeres a tener a tres
hijos para revertir esta desaceleración
de la natalidad Pero Raúl simplemente
para concluir hemos visto en estos
últimos días Muy claramente un ejemplo
por en italiano concretamente donde una
mujer ha llegado por primera vez a la
máximo nivel de poder ejecutivo hablamos
de Georgia meloni que asumió como
primera ministra y eso no significa para
nada que al frente del gobierno italiano
vaya a ver una política feminista al
contrario no Georgia meloni ataca
constantemente una supuesta ideología de
género o ni siquiera feminista Rosa sino
simplemente respetar los derechos
civiles bueno Raúl pero digamos que el
feminismo se considera no respetar los
Derechos Humanos teniendo en cuenta que
las mujeres son personas gracias a Rosa
como siempre por toda la información
nosotros Entonces saludamos a nuestra
primera invitada al día